a home invasion caught on camera in the
northwest valley now the homeowner is
hoping the community will step up and
help identify the burglars mary jane
belliesa has more in his message about
being vigilant so this doesn't happen to
you
it was 2 30 in the afternoon when
homeowner mike thompson says thieves
broke into his home in the providence
neighborhood in this surveillance
footage from two weeks ago you can see a
black toyota corolla driving up and down
the street before parking in front of
thompson's driveway
they drove back and forth a couple of
times and they parked right in front of
the driveway got out
went around the back of the house jumped
the wall
broke in through the back window
they weren't hiding at all there were a
couple of guys working on the street
it was pretty bold thompson says his
security footage inside his home
captured two people one man even
attempting to cover up the security
camera he says it only took a matter of
minutes before the thieves were in and
out of the home making a getaway while
the alarm was going off
took what they wanted
and left out through the front door
i was at work
that's the good part about it everybody
was at work
so this stuff can be replaced thompson
says metro police arrived quickly and he
was able to file a police report he is
thankful his family is safe and wants
the community to stay on alert get to
know your neighbors
we didn't know all our neighbors until
that day
exchange phone numbers
so you can call each other if something
doesn't look right listen to what your
neighborhood dogs are barking at
because it's not always the amazon guy
keep your eyes and ears open and don't
be afraid to call metro they were
fantastic mary jane bellaza live local
now